Find the probability of rolling
even numbers three
times using a six-sided die
numbered from 1 to 6.
So let's just figure out the
probability of rolling it each
of the times.
So the probability of rolling
even numbers.
So even roll on six-sided die.
So let's think about
that probability.
Well, how many total
outcomes are there?
How many possible rolls
could we get?
Well, you get one, two, three,
four, five, six.
And how many of them satisfy
these conditions, that it's an
even number?
Well, it could be a 2,
it could be a 4, or
it could be a 6.
So the probability is the events
that match what you
need, your condition for right
here, so three of the possible
events are an even roll.
And it's out of a total of
six possible events.
So there is a-- 3 over 6 is
the same thing as 1/2
probability of rolling
even on each roll.
Now they're going to
roll-- they want to
roll even three times.
And these are all going to
be independent events.
Every time you roll, it's not
going to affect what happens
in the next roll, despite what
some gamblers might think.
It has no impact on what happens
on the next roll.
So the probability of rolling
even three times is equal to
the probability of an even roll
one time, or even roll on
six-sided die-- this thing over
here is equal to that
thing times that thing again.
All right, that's our first
roll-- we copy and we paste
it-- times that thing and then
times that thing again.
Right?
That's our first roll,
which is that.
That's our second roll.
That's our third roll.
They're independent events.
So this is going to be equal to
1/2-- that's the same 1/2
right there-- times 1/2
times 1/2, which is
equal to 1 over 8.
There's a 1 in 8 possibility
that you roll even numbers on
all three rolls.
On this roll, this roll,
and that roll.